in der engadiner bergwelt liegt das
hochalpine instituten
hier lernen und wohnen schüler von nah
und fern
schäfer aus sankt petersburg befindet
sich im letzten jahr des gymnasiums
schulkollegin batliner wohnt in spuren
und besucht die sportklasse
auch für robin aus der innerschweiz
finden sich nun die weichen fürs leben
ein team von internet betreuen kümmert
sich um die freuden und sorgen der
jugendlichen
und gerhard steuble amt als rektor des
traditionsreichen instituts
für alle ist es das jahr der
entscheidungen
[Musik]
zeva rubine und ein weiterer kollege
gehören zu den ältesten im internet
eigentlich gilt ein alkoholverbot am
hochalpinen institut deshalb möchte auch
niemand die wodkaflasche bei sich
behalten
[Musik]
am anderen ende des areals kontrolliert
internats betreuerin und biopsie schüler
in der turnhalle verstecken sie hat
heute nachtschicht und ist somit
verantwortlich für die 60 jugendlichen
die im internat wohnen
bis um mitternacht wird sie unterstützt
von ihrem kollegen grant fletcher
er ist zuständig für die jungs während
ruth berlau sich um die mädchen kümmert
robin und sie wohnen im internat im
vierten stock die flasche alkohol sind
sie noch nicht losgeworden sie suchen
unterstützung um sie zu leeren
ihr zimmer nachbar kommt eben aus dem
kraftraum
[Musik]
eine große hilfe in sachen schnaps
trinken ist er hier nicht mehr
[Musik]
in der letzten sendung der
internatsschule nahm das schuljahr
seinen anfang
der russe silva puschkin kam mit seinen
eltern direkt von einer europa reise ins
internat
rektor gerd stoll ist die neuen schüler
willkommen
die bündnerin marina dance die an einem
bein handicapiert ist startete ebenfalls
in ihr abschlussjahr am gymnasium
und robin pic ist präsentierte den plan
für seine maturaarbeit
[Musik]
mit
er will fünf tage alleine im wald
überleben
[Musik]
es gibt regeln im internat des
hochalpinen instituts
so sind neben alkohol auch toaster und
andere elektrogeräte verboten
robben ist nicht dabei
drüben im mädchen trägt scheint alles
geordnet zuzugehen ruth birne
kontrolliert ob alle im bett sind
[Musik]
doch auch die mädchen halten sich nicht
immer an die regeln
da ist jemand zu viel im zimmer
royal er schlägt sich mit
erziehungsproblemen darum wie sie die
meisten eltern können
im boden trakte macht grant fletcher
eine letzte kontrollrunde
schnell wird die toaster küche
eingestellt
[Musik]
die truppe verteilt sich unverdächtig
auf dem ganzen
[Musik]
grand fletcher lässt es bei einer
oberflächlichen visite bewenden für
einmal drückte ein auge zu
es ist kurz vor mitternacht ruth berlau
wird für den rest der nachtschicht
allein im internet dienst tun
die nacht bleibt tatsächlich ruhig
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen um 7 uhr früh die
beiden köche sind die ersten die am
hochalpinen institut mit der arbeit
beginnen
frühstück ist nicht obligatorisch
manche der schüler schlafen lieber zehn
minuten länger andere wie sie halten das
frühstück möglichst kurz
einer greift nochmals ordentlich zu
robin pictures bald wird er für seine
maturaarbeit in den wald ziehen und sich
nur von dem ernähren was die natur ihm
bietet
dieses postauto ist eigentlich ein
schwules
denn darin sitzen nur jugendliche aus
dem unterengadin welche am hochalpinen
institut fan zur schule gehen so auch
mal einer gartens firma leiner und die
anderen 70 jugendlichen aus der region
ist das hochalpine institut eine normale
öffentliche schule im unterricht treffen
die so genannte externen auf die
kollegen welche im internat wohnen für
diese ist das hochalpine institut eine
privatschule welche rund 45.000 franken
pro jahr kostet
[Musik]
auch rektor gerhard schäuble macht sich
für den unterricht bereit alles in allem
hat der rund 130 schülerinnen und
schüler an seinem institut
130 schüler sind eigentlich zu wenige um
die schule zu finanzieren
vor ein paar jahren waren es noch 200
schüler
hammer was jetzt aus dem tag und haben
einen lang lagen darum kämpft dass man
aus
rückläufigkeit durch räume und da haben
bereits praktische verein schulungen
auch etwas stabilisiert und unternehmen
jetzt einen möglichen größeren rückgang
wohne ich hoffe dass man im verlauf vom
jahr nach und rita kompensieren möchte
ich nicht immer gleich als eine landmine
zu hause ganz gut finanziell bewältigt
aber es kommt ziel sind ganz klar
konturiert rektor steuble hat mit
strukturellen problemen zu kämpfen
infolge des geburtenrückgangs gibt es
weniger schüler in den städten wächst
die konkurrenz durch private schulen und
der teure schweizer franken erschwert
das geschäft mit ausländischen kunden
[Musik]
willkommen bei den mädchen der
abschlussklasse beginnt der tag mit
turnen ihr bekommt hier note für
leistung ihr bekommt hier nothilfe das
was hier effektiv macht nicht fürs
zuschauen ich es nicht da sein nicht für
irgendwelche dummen bemerkungen sondern
für eben eure leistung gute leistung
gibt es eine gute note
was ja heißt der erste stunde sport
eine deiner fast lieblingsdisziplin
es geht los
nicht mit dabei im turnunterricht ist
mir leider gottes
sie trainiert einen stock höher in
konditions- rahmen die 19-jährige ist
teil der sportklasse trotz ihrer
behinderung
batliner ist mehrfache schweizer
meisterin im schwimmen in der
sportklasse trainiert sie für ihre
zweite leidenschaft den langlauf
seit ihrer geburt ist beim ad leitha das
rechte bein kürzer als das linke
[Musik]
gleich lang sie aber zwar dabei fällt
zwischen ganz komplett gesagt
das hochalpine institute daran ist eine
von fünf anerkannten swiss olympic
sports puls der schweiz
batliner hat prominente vorgänger
besonders im langlauf und snowboard
hatten einige topathleten hervorgebracht
unter ihnen olympiasieger dario cologna
[Musik]
448 wiederholen ok
mit maximal 2
[Musik]
oberkörper und arme trainiert marina
intensiv wegen ihrer behinderung kann
sie sich im langlauf nur mit kräftigen
stößen vorwärts bewegen im gegensatz zu
ihrer konkurrenz
[Musik]
um halt vorn etwas nicht probieren muss
man
dann findet das dem schneider sap-system
machen mit dem handicap
aber es gibt ja halt machen wird
es mal probiert und anlage wieder
mit lenas mutter hat ihre tochter schon
von kleinauf animiert sich zu bewegen
und so ist der sport zu einem zentralen
teil ihres lebens geworden
[Musik]
erhöht sind die kleinen unter gross
rektor gerhard schäubles schulstunde
beginnt
naja
seit 32 jahren ist gerhard steuble
lehrer vor viereinhalb jahren übernahm
er den rektor posten am hochalpinen
instituts
gleichwohl behielt steuble ein kleines
pensum von sechs wochenstunden als
lehrer
ärzte country
gymnasialklasse mathematik und wieso
lehrer im format von google bing und
furchtbare angst tätig war man ihn immer
lehrer war dass sie da wird niemand
begriff aber sie territorien abgehört
und schüler verändert sich die situation
verändert sich und jetzt geht es mir
darum dass sie die veränderungen einfach
die immer mitbekommen hat dass sie so
losgelöst an rektor bin überhaupt
schaffen immer verstand
könne noch keine angst
ein paar schritte entfernt beginnt der
unterricht für die schüler der 6 gegen
die matur klasse von robin see war und
beinahe im moment ist von den drei enorm
alleine da der deutschlehrer trägt die
abwesenheiten in den computer ein in das
elektronische klassenbuch
und auch sie war kommt etwas zu spät
spaß gemacht pro minute die man so spät
kommt für die pflege stützt
also dass männer nicht da
und robin zwei schüler fehlen immer noch
drüben im internet büro hat ruth berlau
zugriff auf das elektronische kassenbuch
der
european raw
bemüht sich wirklich mit filz war
robin ist an einer bewilligten sitzung
der schüler organisation erfährt bei
ihrer später
bemerkt
das ist die
hauptaufgabe dass sie regelmäßig zu
besuchen
um nachzuschauen was es mit der zweiten
abwesenheit auf sich hat gedroht
barriere rüber in den mädchen trakt
[Musik]
sie hat einen teller mit früchten dabei
was ist los
hast du mich wenn ich
habe dir etwas gebracht
es ist gut
okay du hast du
bereits seit drei jahren betreut bei
lala jasmina sie können die leidige
geschichte mit den migräneattacken und
weiß dass sie gegen diese anfälle nicht
viel ausrichten kann
ist das mit yasmina tun jetzt noch
einfacher geht es nicht darum ob und wie
viel
passiert betrifft mich gehabt
jetzt soll es über das sind lediglich
schäfer puschkin nimmt die nächste
schulstunde mit einem mulmigen gefühl in
angriff
die rückgabe einer prüfung ist
angekündigt
wir haben abgemacht dass ich euch die
prüfungen zurückgeben
der einzige der den test nicht
absolviert hat ist selber und er hat ihn
auch nicht gestern geschrieben obwohl
wir das so abgemacht hatten
der durchschnitt beträgt 4,6 inklusive
der einst von silber
scheint es nicht gross zu kümmern dass
er nun im abschlussjahr steht
klassenlehrer mario zankl ist nicht eben
begeistert von seinem schulischen
einsatz
bist du müde ein stillleben liegend auf
dem tisch großartig
um die natur zu schaffen muss ich sie
war deutlich steigern
noch bleiben ihm und den anderen
schülern der abschlussklasse ein
dreiviertel jahr
also das ist die sechste g und die bin
da in der sechsten relativ tolerant ich
gesagt dass es ihre dass es ihrer
verantwortung und ihre aufgabe das ist
die reifeprüfung die reifeprüfung klasse
und sie müssen diese reife beweisen wenn
er denkt er muss darum hängen dann soll
herum hängen und es beweist mir halt er
ist einfach nicht reif jetzt dafür
[Musik]
seine energie und setzt sie war lieber
im kraftraum 1
unterstützt von lauter musik ohne große
rücksicht auf die anderen
draußen versucht sich robin auf sand
tennis zu konzentrieren
[Musik]
sie im konzert vom seewasser kritisch
heute ist sport abend für alle die im
internat wohnen
[Musik]
seewald mit seinem harten rock die ganze
veranstaltung ihn kümmert das wenig
[Musik]
ich mache dich ja was sich aber genau
dafür darf man nicht bloß
[Musik]
auf reibereien gehören dazu in einem
internat müssen die jugendlichen lernen
miteinander auszukommen
[Musik]
so wunderschön gelegen die
internatsschüler ist so abgelegen ist
sie auch abgesehen von sport können die
jugendlichen hier nur wenig unternehmen
im 400 seelen dorf läuft nichts die
nächste größere ortschaft ist stuhl mit
2300 einwohner unter ihnen hotline
agents und ihr vater
ihn zog es nach der pensionierung zurück
an seinen heimatort während matt liners
mutter mit der kleinen schwester in der
nähe von chur blieb
das ist sicher mama gehst du
kleiner hätte auch bei der mutter wohnen
bleiben können nicht zuletzt wegen der
schule entschied sie sich nach spur zu
ihrem papa zu ziehen
ja das ist in
der familie gaudenz wird rätoromanisch
gesprochen
seine profession dauerlauf
nummer zur teile krieg tochter und
mutter starten beim frauenlauf
zuvorderst
sind hat er deshalb nicht
absichern
das hätte werk waren eigentlich aber das
ist viel zu streng das ganztag auf einen
beistand und
das wäre in sachen und erträgen und
die mechaniker dass das nix
also genug zeit ich jetzt mit dem verlag
vor den bug ist auf jeden fall
lang stoff da beides stimmt
dass
akzeptierst
ausprobieren
noch weiß man leider nicht in welche
berufliche richtung sie nach der matur
gehen will
an der internatsschule dann beginnt das
wochenende
am freitagnachmittag haben alle frei nun
gehe nicht nur die unterengadiner
schüler nach hause sondern auch die
meisten aus dem internat
[Musik]
für robin beginnt heute das große
abenteuer er ruht in der küche eine
letzte stärkung die kölner gut
gebrauchen denn für seine maturaarbeit
wieder die nächsten fünf tage alleine im
wald verbringen
die schüler müssen sich bei
internatsleiter jens bauer abmelden
müssen ja genau wissen wer ist jetzt
noch im haus und wer ist schon weg und
dann ist es auch so dass natürlich wir
versuchen darauf zu achten dass gerade
am freitag nicht jemand erfährt als
unterrichts aus hat und dann versuchen
natürlich manche leute sich einfach
nicht abzumelden und einfach zu fahren
damit wir nicht sagen können hey du
kannst noch nicht fahren und nicht
abmelden ist eigentlich so mit das
schlimmste vergehen meist sei das ein
grund dass man sich nicht ab meldet das
hat er meistens den grund dass man dazu
noch schule schwänzt verlagen zu machen
viele der jugendlichen haben einen
nachhauseweg von drei stunden und mir
deshalb dürfen sie bereits am freitag
nach dem mittag losziehen wieder
einrücken müssen sie dann am
sonntagabend
[Musik]
nicht ganz alle schüler gehen nach hause
eine handvoll jugendlicher die meisten
aus dem ausland bleibt auch am
wochenende im internet unter ihnen cefa
puschkin
gegen langeweile organisiert das
internet team ausflüge aber zu einem
großen teil muss ich sie war selber
beschäftigen
drüben im schultrakt ist noch jemand
rektor gerhard steuble brütet über den
finanzen
er ist oberster chef von 64 mitarbeitern
und führt nicht nur eine schule sondern
zusätzlich einen hotelbetrieb und eine
sportabteilung
das ist dann je nach verlauf von ganze
ist das eigentlich
zweimalige dass das ganze
nur
laufen und dass sie alle belange auf das
als pädagoge schafft es wirtschaftlich
läuft sehr der mitarbeiter wohl fühlt
die sorgen ängste und nöte älterer
über den verlauf oder ausbildet
entwickelt von kind und im moment
unterschrieben oder zauberer von
hochgefahren
aber das denn so was hab ich alles
alleine machen still in nizza also da
gibt es viele gute geister in husum oder
mit 1000
aber in
der stadt tut der staat trägt die
gesamtverantwortung und ersatz der kann
ist er
rektor steuble für das institut sowohl
pädagogisch wie auch
betriebswirtschaftlich finanziert wird
das unternehmen durch schulgebühren wie
auch durch öffentliche gelder der
unterengadiner gemeinden
rechnungen im wert von 170 tausend
franken gibt steuble frei
nun wartet auch auf ihn eine roll seines
wochenende
für jemand anderen drohen die nächsten
tage eher ungemütlich zu werden in der
wildnis ist robin fix auf der suche nach
einem schlafplatz
im rahmen seiner maturaarbeit hat sich
robin zum ziel gesetzt fünf tage im wald
zu überleben er hat kein essen dabei und
kein zelt nur ein messer ein feuerstein
und eine trinkflasche
das ist jetzt
platz
für selber ziemlich
wasserdicht nicht
als erstes baut robin eine kleine hütte
einen schlafsack hat er nicht eingepackt
die hütte muss ihn vor wind und wetter
schützen
mit einem survival kurs und büchern hat
sich robin auf sein abenteuer
vorbereitet ganz wohl scheint es ihm
dennoch nicht zu sein
ist schwierig ist irgendwie vor dem
unbekannten vorm versagen und ich mir
nicht natur kennen und so dass man das
einfach irgendwie
dass man das netz laut lawrow will das
macht eine wenn man das irgendwo vor
dann geht es irgendwie panik und
panischen hier gut das brauchtum energie
und gegen razzien ausland gehörten auch
verloren und
war gegen 1 situationen
denn dann wissen wir eigentlich so
ruhigen wirklich liebe und auch immer
schlechte sternwarte
beim hochalpinen instituts startet
gerhard steuble zu einer mountainbike
tour
gemeinsam mit seinen söhnen jan und
mario
beide haben hier am institut das
gymnasium besucht
dass ich irgendwie spezial was fahrer
das animiert so
aber da bin ich noch nicht
eingeleitet sie hat ein wirklich fahrer
[Musik]
direkt hinter dem institut beginnt die
mountainbike tour hoch auf die allmend
500 höhenmeter sind zu überwinden
[Musik]
mit jedem meter den sich gerhard steuble
vom hochalpinen institut entfernt treten
die beruflichen belastungen mehr in den
hintergrund
nach einer knappen stunde fahrt ist das
ziel erreicht
[Musik]
2202 meter hoch liegt die alpar ad
[Applaus]
gerhard stoll söhne leben beide nicht
mehr zu hause mario studiert in
deutschland und schon in zürich
dennoch haben sie eine enge beziehung zu
ihrem vater und kennen die belastung und
die der rektor posten mit sich bringt
irgendwie zeigen richtig lohnen nach
irgendwas wir nicht so gar nicht nur
noch will irgendwas verpasst hat und
auch eine pflicht menge halbe stunde
oder so die nyt bemerkt nach der
halbzeit blieb ist eine halb stunde
zählt das nicht einmal oder so und dann
sagen wir
warten mal ab oder so nach einer noch
einer ist meistens durchliefen bio oder
öko erzählt er
aber wenn es auch bei lauschte gezogen
danach geht schon mal operiert das immer
lange bis mit dankbar unterwegs sind
aber das lösen sich aber natürlich auch
und das kann ich schon von früheren habe
früh erkannt
die familie ist gerhard stolpes rückrat
ein rückhalt den er in den nächsten
monaten besonders brauchen wird
[Musik]
inzwischen hat robin seine hütte fertig
gebaut
doch es bleibt keine zeit für eine pause
sein magen knurrt
heidelbeeren sollen seinen hunger
stillen
hofft gegen eine chance nach dem tee was
ich sage
das jetzt geplant als nacht
nach einer sprung der beeren sammeln
kehrt robin zurück zum nachtlager
nun steht eine wichtige aufgabe an er
muss ein feuer entfachen
auf leicht brennbare distel blätter das
bild eher magnesium splitter die er dann
mit einem funken entzündet
[Musik]
schluss
mit
[Musik]
das feuer soll robin bis tief in die
nacht während spenden
für
heidelbeeren am lagerfeuer rubins erstes
nachtessen alleine im wald
ohne camping mathe oder schlafsack
versucht robin es sich in seiner hütte
gemütlich zu machen
den boden der hütte hat er mit langem
gras gepolstert
immerhin spielt ihm das wetter keinen
streich es bleibt trocken
noch kann robin von seinen körperlichen
reserven zehren doch er muss noch
weitere vier tage durchhalten ob das
reicht
in der nähe des hochalpinen instituts
brent ebenfalls ein feuer eine kleine
grillparty für jene die über das
wochenende im internat bleiben wie etwas
aber auch ein paar einheimische
jugendliche aus tann und umgebung sind
zur feuerstelle hochgekommen
robin hat seine erste nacht überstanden
bis um 9 uhr hatte es geschafft in
seiner improvisierten hütte zu schlafen
die niemegker an diese käufer denn
nachher sieht ist noch nicht klar
demnach wird immer wieder gebraucht
wurden man sagt du mit dem verlauf am
tag nicht die situation sich noch besser
machen vom boden aber dass er ziemlich
ziemlich wir werden ja und dann
wahrscheinlich und witwe corazon gegen
die
unterschicht druck von gestern
und den toni elias überschrift und der
nächsten tage eine waschechte club
robin begibt sich auf die jagd nicht auf
rasen oder ähnliches er hat es auf
heuschrecken hat gesehen
naja
neumünster wieder weg
damit die heuschrecken nicht wieder
reißaus nehmen und um sie anschließend
essen zu können trennt robin ihnen den
kopf ab
mit schlagzeug und rief ich minute
das
mache ich sofort morgen die nachher
kommt rein
möglicherweise sind sich robin in diesem
moment ein wenig nach dem
frühstücksbuffet im internet
gerüstet sollen die heuschrecken dann
will ich besser schmecken
bei feuer unter dem hintern sind die
heuschrecken selbst kopflos noch zu
sprengen fähig
bleibt noch die hälfte übrig fünf
geröstete heuschrecken
ein bisschen wenig für einen 19 jährigen
an
ich würde gar nicht irgendwie er muss so
oder so würde dass ich jetzt hat mich
nie wie die bad uracher tony machen und
setzt heißt aber einfach durchbeißen und
als mini grenze kennen lernen und wie
durch das
ausreizen
fünf tage will robin insgesamt im wald
bleiben doch er wird sein ziel nicht
erreichen
in der nächsten folge der
internatsschule fan ist robin zurück am
institut
zerlegt sonderschichten ein der
abgabetermin für das matura poster rückt
immer näher
an der geschäftsleitung sitzung muss
rektor gerhard steuble einschneidende
finanzmaßnahmen verkünden
und er kann es heißt dass marcel für den
sport der winter hält einzug
batliner beginnt mit dem lauftraining
und
unvermittelt gerät das hochalpine
institut in einen medialen sturm
zeitungsbericht der kritisieren die
schule massiv ein schock für das ganze
institute
[Musik]